[Music]
help me obi-wan Kenobi
I didn't even know that the film will be
a success I I figured that you know
hopefully would break even maybe I'd
struggle to get the other two babe in
case you hadn't realized this year marks
the 40th anniversary of Star Wars
I think basically I was interested in
you know in mythology and I was really
looking to a way of sort of recreating
what the sort of role mythology played
and I was sort of poking around and I
like sort of spaceships I'm sort of
looking because the Western was the last
real mythological genre and and I
couldn't make it Western westerns were
out of style at that point and I wasn't
that interested in westerns anyway and I
said well now what's going to take over
because nothing is replaced it
nothing replaced the westerns that's
what of the American myths onra and I
said well maybe it'll be space that's no
moon it's a space station and I like
space and space is fun and so we'll
create a kind of fantasy space world
where I can tell some story on some
time-worn stories science fiction was
not very well thought of when I did Star
Wars and he did very hard to get a
science fiction film off the ground
special effects films were almost
non-existent so to do it because they
were considered complicated and people
didn't understand them but to do a you
know complicated science fiction film
involves special effects was unheard of
at that point he just like beggars
Canyon back home
started out that I was going to write a
screenplay in order to write the
screenplay I knew I was going to kind of
start in the middle of something I'd
want to sort of set everything up in a
kind of way so I had to create a world
in order to create that world and
characters on stuff I had to do with
this whole backstory but where everybody
came from and who they were and what
happened and how they got to where they
are and so then I started this moving I
wrote the movie only it was way too big
so and it was three acts I mean so I
took the first act and I said well make
the movie about this because I think I
can get this done it was sort of within
the range of what I can do I made a
movie out of the first act and then that
was such a hit and I was able to do the
second two acts
I told you is good work you have a
favorite moment in Star Wars our scene
um well I have a lot it's you know I
would say in Star Wars that's him going
out looking at the Sun is my favorite
moment
it's the moment that's the most like me
in terms of my view of what I do you
know they're always standing out there
looking at the sunset thinking about
wearing when you go from here